[Applause]
[Music]
how are we very well good excited yes
now we do have the best two spanish
restaurants here head to head and this
is quite weird because you've got two
english running a spanish restaurant and
two spanish running the most amazing
spanish restaurant antonio are you ready
yeah yeah simon in terms of confidence
where'd you sit in one to ten ten ten
yeah fifteen fifteen
fifteen out of ten now okay there's a
competition make this the best service
of your lives yes and you'll be leaving
here
as a winner
el ghetto negra from rippington and
lotto rocker from battersea lock horns
tonight to fight for the spanish title
this is how they got here
earlier this year i asked you to log on
to the f word website and nominate your
favorite local restaurants
the response has been absolutely
phenomenal
you told us about nearly 5 000 different
places you love to eat
and from your nominations it's clear you
go loco for tapas
so i asked my f word team to help me
whittle down your nominations to find
the very best spanish contenders
street fight aubergine's best thing
we're traveling across the country
really putting these nominated
restaurants under severe scrutiny
you nominated spanish restaurants from
scotland to portsmouth and we went to
visit the places you loved to eat
as we searched it soon became clear that
two restaurants were in a league of
their own in ripond and west yorkshire
el gato negro is a very spanish
restaurant run by a very passionate
northerner i suppose you want to expect
a northerner to be cooking spanish food
but you know it works and i love it i
love the products i love i love the
people i love the food and so you know
we're passionate about it simon shaw has
an impressive pedigree he was the
executive chef of harvey nichols in
london but gave up at glamorous city
life to open a spanish restaurant in the
country
there's nothing better that i love than
to be in the middle of barcelona
sat with a beer eating a plate of padron
peppers and i thought you know the
people of yorkshire deserve this
simon is a culinary pioneer and exactly
what i'm looking for hello
how are you sir i'm very well how are
you
i can't wait to see if an english chef
can deliver stunning spanish food
good to see you look at the size of this
kitchen what in the hell are you doing
up here like most restaurant says i went
to open a restaurant didn't have enough
money to do it in london right so i'm
actually from around here
walks in i think it was the right place
for us
local lad matt healy is the sous chef he
knows the quality of elgato negro's
cuisine can win over any critic
if somebody said to me two lads from
north shouldn't be cooking tapas i'd say
book a table a little gatorade on a
saturday night and it'll change your
mind
head chef simon co-owns the restaurant
with flamboyant welshman chris williams
a former colleague from harvey nix
sam and i can have a very temp
tempestuous relationship to remain i can
flip but so consignment
faced with so many tempting dishes i
want to taste a bit of everything
starting with the anchovy crostini good
food pretty good food uh
clean
great flavors simply done more of a
traditional spanish tapas and um yeah
fast this is cooked freshly great
flavors great balance one hell of a
talented chef we we've got our sights
set on winning it so it means a lot i
love a lot if we
win
it would be the dogs
so first impressions this place is warm
um
incredibly warm yeah having searched
across the country there's only two
russians are going through
to cook
in the f-word restaurant and there it's
50 discerning diners that are you know
quite full-on
and
congratulations you're one of them
i look forward to seeing you
back in london
yeah lentil season brilliantly
congratulations ceriso wonderful thank
you prawns wonderful
[Music]
representing el gato negro it's just
it's up there it's up there with
anything i've done before so i'm
very pleased so have one of your idols
tell you that the food is fantastic it's
just
i couldn't top that talented team and
how weird is that amazing tapas not one
spanish person cooking it
anywhere that needs to be celebrated big
time
so el gato negro is through and from
your nominations i found a worthy
opponent to take them on
[Music]
battersea south london is home to lola
rocco a short walk from where i live
[Music]
it's a modern spanish restaurant run by
antonio and christina antonio and i we
got together because of the love for
food the fiery couple from barcelona
have a passionate relationship in and
out of the kitchen
i went into the kitchen and he shouted
to me you know get me this and get me
that and i said you shut up okay because
you know we are under pressure too so
please you know come down and you know
he took it on board
hello
how are you you've been fine fine nice
to see you nice to see you and first
thank you guys christina christina good
to see you and i want to have a little
place
christina prides herself on the fact
that all her staff are from spain
[Music]
her husband antonio is the head chef
he's bold and experimental in the
kitchen with a passion for contemporary
tapas what's all this
this manchego lollipops bloody hell you
make lollipops
that's incredible
antonio insists on importing products
from spain to create a truly authentic
experience for his customers
that's beautiful yes
it's excellent this is octopus this is
from galicia from mexico yes this is
from salamanca beautiful and that's 21
days old yeah yeah i'd love to start
without the octopus a little bit of
chicken and a little taste of the
pointer
first up for me grilled octopus and
potatoes bravos
[Music]
specially
honestly
keep on pitching myself i'm in battersea
rise not barcelona
authentic spanish i mean properly
spanish tapas done brilliantly well
extraordinary well we just hope that
we'll go through
the spanish category yes has been one of
the toughest categories across the
country so
congratulations because you are through
to the f word restaurant
honestly i had an exceptional lunch yeah
congratulations that was extraordinary
beautiful yeah and i've been a big big
big admirer of proper tapas beautifully
done congratulations thank you yes thank
you thank you really good thank you
well done we are very very happy but
we love this this city we love this
country we love the customers now
definitely the right decision mate and
more importantly i'm so frustrated
you know i've been living here for seven
years they've been here for three years
i've never even noticed them and that's
what this competition is all about yeah
unsung heroes cooking authentic proper
spanish tapas like that deserve to be
recognised
[Music]
so i've chosen two remarkable spanish
restaurants from your nominations
will the f-word diners prefer elgato
negro's classic tapas
or lola rocco's contemporary menu
he'll be crowned the f word's best local
spanish restaurant
we're about to find out
we're back in london at the f word
restaurant
and tonight we're going spanish
after searching for months all over the
country we whittle down your nominations
to find the f-word's best two local
spanish restaurants el gato negra in
yorkshire and lolo rocco in south london
okay guys antonio four covers on table
one please four prawns four fish shoe
for chiros yeah
excellent elgato standby don't stop
working yeah on order five kills double
five five prawns yes five sea bass five
curios chef yes chef thank you
right simon the secret behind these
prawns
yeah i mean for me i like a lot of
caramelization on them you really want
to taste that char grill flavor yeah you
left the heads on why is that yeah
there's all the good flavors in it great
flavor in the head good as a northerner
simon has a no-nonsense approach to
spanish tapas
el gato negro may be in the yorkshire
countryside but simon's determined to
bring home the taste of spain
a lot of people that come here actually
ask if this chef spanish so to be able
to say actually no he's from actually
he's quite good
[Music]
elgato for me to like a little slice of
barcelona in west yorkshire which you
just would not expect it's a delight to
have it so close to where we live
for el gato negro starter simon
marinates prawns in lemon garlic and
thyme and then griddles them
he saute them in chorizo butter and
serve them with frittata sauce parsley
oil and balsamic vinegar drizzling over
the remaining chorizo butter
what's in the butter
in the butter uh fine diced chili
paprika chorizo
cabernet sauvignon vinegar yeah and uh
red wine
and the sausage the puree of the of
sausage just just just put in the oven
under salamander very gently just to
release the oils out of it don't cook it
too much and then you're blitzing it and
passing through this blizzard
antonio would you say that simon's
flavor is better we like the the
the plain flavor no that is spicy or
strong and sometimes sometimes yeah
yeah the chorizo yes the chorizo is for
beginners you know for beginners yeah
yeah so he's like a child so it's like
your baby yeah okay got it
yeah excellent so i didn't realize that
you were connected to antonio because
you said you cooked like a baby
well like you smelly two tooths yeah
chorizo's for beginners
antonio has a unique contemporary style
of cooking
opening a restaurant has been antonio's
dream since he was a child growing up in
spain
the family-run business has a warm
atmosphere which is a big hit with the
locals
they love antonio's authentic tapas with
a modern twist
it is the best
tapas i have ever had in london
for antonio starter he coats king prawns
in flour dips them in batter and deep
fries
he skews a hole in the prawns and
inserts a pipette of chive mayonnaise
the prawns are served on a bed of wild
salad and a side of tomato and red
pepper pepperoni
what was the feedback from your
customers when they saw a pipette
sticking out of their prawns
some people
see and say
and the wall is green now
so the paprika at the end what kind of
paprika is that what is that it's the
picante that's a smoked paprika yeah
yeah yeah yeah
is that class for beginners as well
paprika or not yeah the hot paprika yes
[ __ ] you know you can't win either way
can you cerrito yeah paprika if you beat
him tonight you can have a big [ __ ]
smile on your face from here to here the
biggest box of paprika and the biggest
package you've ever seen i'm going to
send them to you in the post
very nice they look beautiful
they all look like they're spreading
little green trees
right in spain goose barnacles are known
as the truffles of the sea and here's
why
[Music]
the atlantic ocean is a chef's dream
galithia on the northwest coast of spain
is home to classic spanish ingredients
like prawns
but that's not all
these waters are bursting with some of
the best seafood in the world the only
problem is the spanish don't like
exporting it so if you really want to
try it you've got to come here and taste
it for yourself
this region is famous for seafood
and there's a shellfish poplar with the
locals you'll only find in a few places
around the world
now these are a huge delicacy here petha
bears commonly known as goose barnacles
now let's be honest they don't exactly
look like the most appetizing of seafood
do they i think they look more like
[ __ ] janet's reporters toenails
however
the secret here is to just twist quickly
and
and out comes this amazing delicacy
flavor
in terms of taste delicious cross
between a razor clam and a sort of
cockle stroke muscle and here's the good
news 300 euros a kilo
full bowl of toenails
wow
these incredibly expensive shellfish may
look weird but they taste delicious
the big question is why do they cost
three times more than fresh lobster
it all became clear when i met up with
local fisherman andres in a secret
location further up the coast
now what in the hell are they doing down
there they're collecting per service
actually
my gosh it is mad it is crazy so what
they're doing they're just dangling over
the side of the
the rock yeah they keep jumping from one
rock to another and uh collecting from
there
actually it's it's very very dangerous
and many people have died collecting
perseverance many people don't yeah many
people are here
the way he jumps i mean it's so [ __ ]
dangerous now yeah it is it is actually
i wouldn't do it myself
this amazing delicacy is found below the
water line stuck firm to the foot of the
craggy spanish coast
but dodging the waves like a matador
seemed a step too far
even for these exquisite little
shellfish
and this spot wasn't actually where the
best ones were hiding
this was
how in the [ __ ] do you get down there
the goose barnacles were at the bottom
of this 300 foot cliff deep beneath the
crashing waves
fishermen like angel and javier risk
their lives almost every day to get
their hands on them is that's where the
best ones are it says
good ones in there the more they enjoy
the best first service the more
dangerous yeah yeah you're
you need to see a doctor
the more the goose barnacles are pounded
by the waves the more muscle they need
to cling onto the cliff so the juicier
fatter and tastier they become
how you get them off the rocks because
they they're attached hard
that's for taking tires off a car
no
now you
you hit the rock and the idea with
pessimists is to get a bit of uh rock
underneath them so they don't die
straight away is that right
so crowbar oh [ __ ] and the pouch at the
side yeah yeah yeah that's all they take
that's it yeah that's it
and a pair of converse and a pair of
combos oh [ __ ]
these are certainly one of the most
extraordinary delicacies i've ever come
across
my god all i have to do is survive long
enough to get my hands on them
this could be the most dangerous thing
i've ever done
okay simon last table yeah
good yeah it's not a race geyser
not a race every plate that went out
from this kitchen look fantastic yeah
really good job yeah well done
thank you antonio well done
okay
for the prawns um the chorizo i thought
might overpower um the flavor of the
prawns but it didn't at all it was like
an infusion it was perfect i could have
eaten it again i thought the dish was
actually really good i thought the
presentation was quite nice um the only
thing i would say is although the prawns
were quite well cooked the churritso
butter wasn't that flavoursome
[Music]
good to see you welcome therefore thank
you very much nice to see you all how do
you think antonio's do very well does it
make you feel incredibly proud
and in terms of the prawns you ate
tonight how were they
i wouldn't mix chorizo with seafood
because chorizo is very overpowering
but i didn't taste the chorizo at all
right so i don't quite understand the
dish in fact i decided not to pay for
that
wow
enjoying main courses yes nice to see
thank you
lovely really nice um we like the way it
was presented
with the pipettes the prawns were
lukewarm
the batter was undercooked
and the novelty factor of the pipettes
not really hi chris good to see you
very much how are you thank you very
much enjoy the food the batter was a bit
soggy for me
in terms of the
modern twist on a spanish dish with a
pipette is that something that works for
you or do you think it's a little bit
too once i got into it but i just wasn't
sure what you had to do with it the big
question is are you going to pay for
them
no no
good to see you thank you have you
enjoyed the main courses
honestly you're like one of those
humbugs that you don't stop sucking
in terms of presentation they both look
fantastic you've got the rustic
old-fashioned charm and this one here
and with a modern twist the secret is to
get the pipette
squeeze
and pull and then into the mouth
that's delicious
really delicious it's quite interesting
that chive mayonnaise against that
crispy batter the sweetness of the prawn
that works very very well
right elgatos
these are cooked on a skewer the fresh
tomato sauce at the bottom
the idea is to squeeze the juice out the
head mix that in with the tomato and
then dip the prawn
really good flavor and the tomato sauce
works with the sweetness of the prawn
however my only slight concern with this
plate is there's oil everywhere if it
was down to me i'd go for the prawns
with a pepper they've tried something
really adventurous here and i have to
say with a chai mayonnaise it does work
lovely
but it's not up to me whoever has the
most diners paying for the food tonight
will be crowned the f words best local
spanish restaurant
first of all before we get the results
yeah i tried both issues i thought they
were fantastic
okay let's find out how you did uh jb
please the results
so
let's start off with
elgato nego
simon and matt the number of customers
out of 25 that are happy to pay yeah for
their starters is
wow
19 out of 25 well done
that's very good
very good indeed
now
feedback jb give it a spice in the
tourism so they wanted more spice the
ones that didn't play the six steadier
on the season 19 loved it clearly yeah
okay good great start 19 out of 25.
okay
the number of customers out of 25 that
are willing to pay
for your starter
is
wow
wow wow wow that is a surprise
nine out of 25.
why
too soggy soggy yeah the salad or the
batter no the batter the batter yeah i
thought those prawns were delicious i
loved that little modern twist of the
pepper i thought that was unique but you
must keep that batter crispy yeah
do not drop your head now that was only
25 to cook for now you've got 50 to cook
for clear down yeah get ready for the
main course well done
now both restaurants are going to be
cooking their main courses first up lola
in their rojo london restaurant antonio
and christina are determined to make
their food authentic
the idea of the restaurant was to mix
very traditional tapas on a contemporary
way everything made from scratch
they serve octopus fresh from golithia
and suckling pig from salamanca
coming from barcelona antonio and
christina have a passion for seafood
so their signature dish tonight is costa
brava fish stew
antonio starts by dusting the turbot and
sea bass fillets in flour salt and
pepper
he fries the fish adding chopped onion
garlic and paprika
it's nice for the color and it's nice
for the flavor
next he grates the tomato
you use the plum tomato because the
flavor of this tomato i think is better
he adds fish stock some bold potatoes
and clams
to thicken the stew antonio creates a
picada paste
he mixes saffron roast almonds fried
bread
garlic and flat leaf parsley
grinds into a paste and adds it to the
stew
it's simmered for a minute and is ready
to go
servies
so antonio the name of the restaurant
came from where
my first girlfriend your first
girlfriend you named your restaurant of
your first girlfriend and does christina
know that
no
simon the secret behind this dish what
is it
uh it's a combination of soup yeah and
the uh sour dressing of the vinaigrette
yeah the
texture in it as well here's what el
gato negro is cooking tonight
el gato negro is a tiny tapas restaurant
in rippendon but head chef simon has
huge aspirations
in his london days he had 35 chefs
working for him but now with a small
team of four simon relies heavily on
right-hand man matt stick him in front
of the stove and just wind him up when
he goes all night so he's right he's
perfect so he's got the looks and i've
got the brains
i've always sort of had the passion and
desire to [ __ ] being able to cook but
simon has just pushed me that little bit
further like he said he's got the brains
and i've got the look so let's make lots
of money you know what i mean check on
boys
elgato negro signature dish is sea bass
with a warm potato rosemary and olive
oil soup
first simon fry's sliced charlotte
potatoes in butter with baby spinach
for the soup he sweats down chopped
shallots and garlic
next he adds peeled and sliced potatoes
rosemary and fish top and simmers for 15
minutes
he blends and sits the mix adding olive
oil and seasoning
to skin the tomatoes he blanches them in
boiling water
i normally count 14 seconds that won't
be out loud that'll be in my head for
the vinaigrette he reduces cherry
vinegar then adds sultanas olive oil
toasted pine nuts the diced tomatoes and
chopped parsley
he seasons the sea bass and fries till
golden
i want to stay nice and straight
[Music]
sea bass with a warm potato rosemary and
olive oil soup served
so simon you're mixing the veggie
spinach in with the potatoes last minute
yeah this is a bit 1970s using rings
yeah i just i just want it to fall
because it's got a soup in there okay
excellent antonio would you put spanish
food in a ring
no not too much no not too much the only
ring you put is on your wife's finger
yes
i love that paprika there's a smoked
paprika yes it's mug paprika but i
thought with the starter you told me you
didn't like smoked paprika yeah
paprika chef hey
only for this for this dish yeah
is that it you happy with that that's it
yeah okay that looks fantastic well done
yeah really good okay well done well
done well done should we go please cross
it off please let's go
so the english are beating the spanish
at their own game
do you think your wife christina will
leave you if you lose to the english
she's very passionate yeah yeah she's
very well if she does leave you can
always go back to your ex-girlfriend
lola can't you huh
very nice thank you that looks lovely go
well done good table one please
now six more
this is fascinating and tony had a
really bad start and his head went down
and sort of started to become a little
bit more demoralized however he started
to pull it back the fish jew is
absolutely delicious i'm so impressed by
antonio's attitude because he seems to
bounce back immediately which is a
really good sign so he's down and he's
definitely not out el ghetto negro that
main course is something quite
interesting about that he's got the
sweaty potatoes mixed with the spinach
this really nice delicious potato and
rosemary soup topped off with this
wonderful sea bass that's got these
really nice acidic raisins bizarre
combination but i think it really works
what's next step after this last next
four we've got four go now
after that yeah yes and we're halfway
there yeah wait
and trust me this is not a racer every
single play counts yeah
make the next half as good as the first
half yeah excellent thank you now goose
barnacles taste absolutely fantastic but
incredibly difficult to get your hands
on
i'm in golithia on the northwest coast
of spain on hunt for one of the rain's
most sought after delicacies
pepper bears or goose barnacles
they're delicious expensive everything a
gourmet ingredient should be
but they're also at the bottom of a 300
foot cliff
my god
the fast flowing water of the atlantic
makes the goose barnacles stronger
fatter and tasty to eat
but absailing into it is the only way to
reach them
my god this is
insane the powerful currents of the
atlantic are not something to mess with
[ __ ]
i must be off my [ __ ] rocker
[Music]
once the waves retreat i've got just 30
seconds before they return to spot the
goose barnacles and wrench them off the
rocks
my guide tells me that if i hear a
whistle
it means that the sea is coming crashing
back in and i have to get out the way
fast
[Music]
the waves are knocking me all over the
place
i can see the goose barnacles
but i keep on being pushed in the wrong
direction
finally i've got my footing
[Music]
you got to be quick
but i'm concentrating so hard on the
prize i forget the first simple rule
[Music]
listen for the whistle
i've lost the [ __ ] stick
[ __ ]
yes
thank you
[Music]
you need a license to collect goose
barnacles like this but i was quickly
starting to think who'd want one given
the risks
oh [ __ ]
breaking them off the rock turns out to
be the easy part i've only collected a
few handfuls
when disaster strikes
everything i collected was lost to the
sea
bag's gone
this is by far the most dangerous
fishing trip i've ever been on
and i only managed a couple of handfuls
before the tide filled the cove
that was hard work
i mean seriously hard work you're
holding on
and then when the wave wipes you out
you're trying to focus on the grip but
everything's just so slippy down there
from 100 foot up as well looks nothing
down there two and a half three meters
high when it comes in it comes in big
time
well
bloody hard
[Music]
great job yes
a great joint job
look at them they're beautiful what does
that mean when they're just slightly red
the quality is the best the quality is
the best i'm going to show you how to do
the perfect pacifier
tapas style yeah excellent
right the ultimate tapas petha vest now
traditionally cooked in sea water so no
salt in there whatsoever
first i'm going to boil them in the sea
water with bay leaves and a little bit
of olive oil cook them for one minute
they stay here in spain as long as it
takes you to say the lord's prayer
once they're cooked i need to remove
their tough skins
right the secret is to peel them when
they're warm
to finish them a sherry sauce with
shallots bay leaves and a touch of fresh
pepper definitely no salt
this is going to be really quick a touch
of sherry
[Music]
nice
couple of tablespoons of cream
bring that up to the boil add the rind
and the juice of one lemon and just
squeeze
push it in there
and then
a couple of tablespoons of the cooking
liquor that lets down the cream and the
secret here is to keep a really nice
delicate balance
lemon out and pepper bears in
now literally in the cream for 30
seconds and finished with fresh parsley
really important to go on that cream for
literally 30 seconds
any longer than that it'll be like
having a mouth full of elastic bands
excellent right gentlemen
path of this slightly different
all right
it is incredible the taste they are
actually loving it are they fishing
tomorrow
yeah
if they find my bag yeah i want my 300
[ __ ] euros back yeah okay yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
good hold on i guess some water guys
well done tonight it's up to the diners
if they don't like it they don't pay
the fish was cooked to perfection the
olive oil and the wilted spinach all
tasted great and it looks superb i
thought that the sultanas or raisins
they were cooked in i think vinegar
either white wine vinegar or something
like that and that was really
overpowering
the fish stew was absolutely amazing a
little bit on the salty side um but but
really really nice and the fish was
cooked perfectly the fish stew was was
very well balanced very well seasoned um
there was a very nice taste of saffron
without being overpowering and the fish
was very well cooked
right elgato negros sea bass
in terms of flavor
sea bass tastes nice um don't really get
the potato on potato the soup with the
set of potatoes that doesn't quite make
sense however what does lift the dish is
there's wonderful raisins and pine nuts
on the top of the sea bass
this is a classic fish stew
nothing glamorous just great bold
flavors
that's lovely perfectly seasoned fish
tube
he's gone really ultra modern on the
starter but for the main course he's
pulled it back a bit two really good
dishes it'll be interesting to see what
the diners prefer it was down to my
choice i'd go with the fish stew
so the results are in right simon
i'm sea bass yeah how well do you think
you did out of 50
40. about 40. with such a great start
you feel less confident only 40 not 50.
more nervous actually more nervous
yeah yeah
antonio
the fish stew out of 50 how old do you
think you've done 14
40. yeah
okay jb please
okay let's go i'll get to negro first
yes the number of customers there that
are happy to pay for your sea bass out
of 50
is
[Music]
well done 32 out of 50. good news
very good news
the um 18 customers that didn't pay
feedback please
too much vinegar too much vinegar yeah
simon happy with that 32 out of 50. uh
so
i wanted to get to 40. yeah okay antonio
the number of guests that are happy to
pay for your fish two out of 50
is
[Music]
38 out of 50. well done
really well done
really well done indeed
that means when you combine the scores
yes there's only four points in it now
there's 25 covers each to cook for the
desserts yes
that means every plate matters and now
this is neck and neck
okay clear down get ready for dessert
good job really good job
now time for the part of the show where
i take on the celebrity and their
favorite dish and tonight it's kelly
brook taking me on with her stuffed
peppers but i reckon it's her who's
gonna get stuffed are you ready oh
really yes i'm excited this is this
proper challenge now what are you
cooking today my daddy okay i'm doing
stuffed peppers right it's the dish that
sounds dreadful
where do you excuse me delicious sorry
delicious oh my god i'm nervous
you're doing a stuffed pepper i'm doing
a stuffed tomato right okay but please
don't copy me
so look this is tried and tested you
grew up with a love of food i did indeed
my mom's a fantastic cook actually ready
what kind of things the mum used to cook
when you were a kid um roast dinners
yeah um zucchini pie she cooks
everything from indian foods chinese
food
so sweat the onions off a little bit of
color touch of allspice and cinnamon
cook out the spices otherwise there's
that real raw flavor across the mints oh
abby's are hot pretty much ready to
start
making the mints now i think you live
with danny yes yes your long-term
boyfriend yeah yes rugby star he's a lot
younger than you does he keep on your
toes younger
than a few years i'm eight years older
than my wife tyler oh yeah yeah she
keeps me on my toes in a big way i mean
a massive weight okay he's known he's
younger than you so he keeps you on your
toes for celebrities i think i'd give
him a run for his money show me your
kitchen shoes what have you got on
oh i've got some prada mary jane's on
is that not appropriate
right you've blanched your peppers in
boiling water i've blanched mine in
boiling water to take the skin off so
peeled and cut the tops off now and then
scrape out the insides i've just put in
half a teaspoon of this cinnamon yup a
little pinch of mint a little pinch of
oregano just to kind of flavor the mints
you've got fresh mint i prefer dried
mint i think it's tastier really about
you uh do you know what when freshman
available over dried i'd rather go fresh
all the time is that just because you're
a bit of a snobby
far for me let's not trust me because i
want to win
now i'm toasting my pine nuts
in with the mints yeah i'm gonna add um
half a cup of rice
chop the remaining bits of tomato up two
thirds mince one third rice and then
just finish that with a little zest of
lemon
and lemon juice what's that that you're
making a little bit drizzle to go over
the peppers you are so technical you
know that
do you like eating food like this so do
you do you like pancake food i'll eat
anything because you make ponzi food
don't you
three michelin stars
french food
did you say food gives you gas it was
horrendous so kelly's put fitted cheese
at the bottom i'm going at the top of my
tomatoes with a feta now that's what i
was gonna do actually i'll put mine in
the bottom right the peppers and the
tomatoes now go in the oven for half an
hour we come back and the blind tasers
get to taste them right welcome back to
the f word now time for the results of
the recipe challenge excited very
excited
they do look alright actually they do
look good
what do you think it looks fantastic off
you go
ah thank you good job jb thank you good
job
hi
there you go
should we start with this one
oh i can smell the cinnamon
yeah
i'm a big fan of cinnamon yeah me too
oh and a bit of feta i think should we
try the next one
i think that one looks nicer this looks
a little bit burnt on the outside
quite like that
the aftertaste of the meat is pretty
good though i'm so terrified i can't
even know you you know he's got that
little smirk on his face okay come on
then uh give me the good news and
deliver kelly the bad news all right so
um what was the score it's four to one
of course it'll be four to one
is
[Applause]
the rice wasn't cooked properly why do
they like candies they love the spices
the cinnamons and all that stuff i
remember dried herbs i put fresh herbs
in mine i put love into mine you just
put a lot of anger for what i like
you know love
i love your food for one are you not
three two
oh jesus christ i'm busy i've got to
move on but it was nice working with you
[Laughter]
right all right congratulations i've
been stuffed do me a favor get out my
kitchen what
right now it's time for my dessert
churros and chocolate
churros with hot chocolate the spanish
equivalent to our donuts hot sticky and
incredibly moorish first off the hot
chocolate 300 milliliters of double
cream
vanilla pod
cinnamon stick
chili
[Music]
orange zest
heat and infuse
strain
150 grams of dark chocolate
melt
next the churros though 200 milliliters
of water
50 grams of butter
melt
add flour to the mixer
with a pinch of salt
pour in the melted butter and mix to a
smooth paste
bag
fill
chill
hot pan
vegetable oil
pipe
snip
the secret now is to get the dough
really nice and crispy
caster sugar and ground cinnamon coat
chocolate
[Music]
[Applause]
churros with hot chocolate
done
both brigades are making my spanish
dessert recipe
simon something you've put on your menu
i haven't done them as yet but we'd love
to do them very nice the scores are
close everything rests on this last
course
guys make this count yes there's only
four points different in this let's go
if elgato negra take the title tonight
it will propel this tiny place into the
big time i don't want to go all that way
to you know do a half half a job so
we we've got our sights set on winning
it
and victory for lola rocco will mean a
local london restaurant becomes a star
in the capital to win the competition
would be exciting that achievement is
amazing
so gentlemen i'm telling you simon
these last dishes here okay are going to
determine who's first new second yeah
every plate make sure you're exactly
over it yeah
you're only four points behind yeah come
on
churros are a classic spanish street
food but i think they make a great
dessert
they're deceptively tricky to make but
well worth the effort now why are your
churros bigger than simon's why yeah
because we need four points more good
service please tell us sixteen
not too many there antonio and tony
needs to be careful too many in the
fryer and they won't cook properly
four more way this is the last table yes
okay
last two portions matt okay keep it
going
excellent
right churros
elgatonegro can they beat the spaniards
at their own classic dessert a lot
smaller
cooked in the center
sauce
they're good
right
wow
that's surprising a little bit too big
but more importantly
that
is raw
that tip there's just cooked
taste wise fantastic chocolate sauce
brilliant however i'm absolutely
devastated of the rawness and for me the
big question across these desserts is
why don't they cook one and taste it
the chocolate sauce was lovely and gooey
and really really nice and the donuts
were lovely as well really lots of
cinnamon on them so they're really
delicious fantastic absolutely delicious
the crispiness on the outside softer so
just dip it in the chocolate fantastic
i liked the cinnamon flavor on the
churros however the dough was sticky
inside i don't know whether that was
because it was undercooked or whatever
but it was a bit sticky inside the
chocolate was fine
but for me the tourist uh was
undercooked
so the results are in and it's time to
find out who's our winner tonight uh
simon how old do you think you did
uh not as confident as a main course if
i'm honest no antonio uh you grew up
with them
out of 25 customers how well do you
think you did
15 15
16.
okay let's find out how you did uh jb
thank you
right let's start off with la voca
now for dessert the number of customers
happy to pay
out of 25
is
blimey
14 out of 25.
11 customers
didn't pay why not one main reason
undercooked
did you taste the first one second one
white tears
so elgato negro
that means if you get more than 10
then you are the f word's best
local spanish restaurant
okay
the number of customers that are happy
to pay
for your dessert out of 25.
[Music]
it's 23 out of 20.
[Applause]
welcome
now
do yourselves a big favor get out there
and get a glass of fino well done sell
the gold well done yes congratulations
welcome really well
congratulations yes
well done
are straight into fourth place on the f
word leader board but will their score
earn them a place in the semi-final
you